Magnet motor ein motor der. Ohne energiezufuhr ewig läuft eines der dauerbrenner themen die
Ihr euch in der web community gewünscht habt und er wird schon seit jahrzehnten diskutiert
Kann das funktionieren und wie funktionieren elektromotoren überhaupt und kann es solch
ein magnet motor geben jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Nicht nur in elektrofahrzeugen sondern auch in haushaltsgeräten und den modernen anlagen ist die elektrische antriebstechnik
Entscheidend dafür den energieverbrauch, zu senken also wird intensiv nach modernen möglichkeiten geforscht sie
So energieeffizient wie möglich zu gestalten jetzt soll es sogar. Einen motor. Geben der komplett. Ohne
Energiezufuhr mit dauermagneten funktionieren soll weil sie für elektromotoren. Kommen
Unterschiedliche motor technologien in frage als standard wird der drehstrom
Asynchronmotor eingesetzt doch als echte alternative
Dazu erweist sich immer mehr der so genannte permanent erregte synchronmotor vor allem in niedrigen leistungsbereich
synchronmotor bedeutet dass es
Keinen schluss zwischen rotor und stator dreh fällt gibt das erkläre ich jetzt wie etwa bei der drehstrom
asynchronmotor der strato also die durch spulen erzeugten
Elektromagnete schneller als der rote also dieses feld das sie, erzeugen sie werden ständig. Zwischen nord- und südpol umgepolt
Um den rotor antreiben zu können und das passiert kreisförmig damit sie, ihn treiben können muss dieses dreh fällt
So wird es genannt weil es sich eben praktisch dreht schneller laufen als der rotor also der kern der dadurch angetrieben wird nur
dann kann
ein
elektrischer strom durch die spulen induziert werden
Das ist übrigens die motoren konstruktion die inzwischen am weitesten verbreitet ist egal ob tesla oder ic
Überall findet sich dieses konstruktionsprinzip es ist einfach und effizient beim
Permanentmagnetmotor ist das anders die
permanentmagnete führen, zu einer magnetisierung des rotors das passiert verlustlos
So steigt der wirkungsgrad des motors gegenüber dem
Asyl pro motor zudem brauchen permanentmagnetmotor weniger anlauf energie. Und zeigen außerdem auf vorteile beim häufigen anfahren
permanentmagnete haben, zwei pole nord und südpol
Und ihre magnetfeld breitet sich pilz bzw kugelförmig aus ihre magnetfeldlinien sind gekrümmt
Und laufen von nord nach süd. Um, eine drehbewegung zu erhalten, benötigt, man
Zwei selbe pole die sich gegenüberstehen und deren magnetkraft sich ab stößt
Der. Gegenpol der mit derselben kraft eine anziehende wirkung aus ist muss dagegen im richtigen moment geschwächt sein
Um die drehbewegung zu ermöglichen. Um diesen pohl abzuschirmen kann
Eisen oder verriet eingesetzt werden doch wie können permanentmagnete hergestellt werden der energieaufwand ist sowohl bei der rohstoffgewinnung
Als auch bei der herstellung
relativ, groß
Ferromagnetische metalle in pulverform wie kobalt nickel. Und eisen sowie
Legierungen aus eisen bor oder neodym dienen als ausgangsstoffe für die herstellung
besonders starker magnete während der herstellung und des prez vorgangs wird durch, ein elektromagnet
ein besonders starkes magnetfeld erzeugt dass die magnetisierung ermöglicht
Dann, wird der preis liegt bei rund 1000 grad gewinnt hat also verfestigt noch vor kurzer
Zeit waren die preise für die magnete sehr, hoch bei für ihre fertigung
Teure seltene erden notwendig sind durch die erschließung neuer minen sind die. Kosten mittlerweile wieder runter gegangen
Dennoch sind die investitionskosten enorm. Hoch und dennoch. Kommen sie, ihn immer mehr anwendungen zum
Einsatz beispielsweise in haushaltsgeräten wie waschmaschinen aber auch
industriellen antrieben wie punkten gebläsen
und kompressoren die vorteile der permanent magnet motoren also noch einmal zusammengefasst sie weisen eine höhere effizienz bei
Niedrigen drehzahlen auf es gibt keine verluste bezüglich des rotors. Und auch der höhere
Leistungsfaktor ist nicht zu verachten aber auch die nachteile liegen auf der hand sowohl montage. Und wartung als auch die demontage
Gestalten sich schwierig da jetzt gibt es aber noch den magnet motor ein motor der. Ohne energiezufuhr eine drehbewegung ausübt
Und zwar nur mit hilfe von dauermagneten. Also eine art tapete
Um mobile dass durch die spezielle anordnung der sich anziehenden abstoßen pole dauerhaft in einer drehbewegung
Gehalten werden soll schon in den 60er. Jahren hatte ein deutscher maschinenbau behauptet einen magnet motor erfunden
Zu haben der bis zu 20 jahre am stück
Laufen könnte doch selbst im jahr 2006 lehnte das europäische patentamt den
Antrag für ein magnet motor ab sein erfinder wurde 2010 wegen schweren brooks verurteilt feststehen
Jedenfalls magnete können arbeit durch anziehung. Und abstoßung verrichten doch diese muss man auch aufwenden
Um sie anzunähern bzw zu trennen solch ein system funktioniert
Also keineswegs als kreis prozess der immer während energie liefert. Ein solcher motor würde immer, einen gleichgewichtszustand
anstreben, und über kurz oder lang auslaufen wie alles was sich dreht und nicht angetrieben wird vielleicht habt
Ihr im physikunterricht, mal vom energie erhaltungs satz gehört demnach ändert
Sich die gesamtenergie eines abgeschlossenen systems nicht denn. Um, einen
Permanentmagneten zu erzeugen muss zunächst energie reingesteckt werden
Und zwar eine menge aber ja gehört konkret müssen die teilchen des magneten gleichgerichtet werden
Und zwar durch energieaufwand nämlich in einem elektromagnetischen feld und das wird durch strom erzeugt. Danach kann
Dann, ein permanent magnet andere. Magnetische stoffe anziehen
Und verrichtet dabei arbeit und die muss dann auch aufgewendet werden
um
Eine trennung entgegen der kraft hinzubekommen im klartext die
Energiebilanz liegt bei 0 und aus dem system lässt sich keine energie gewinnen das system wird stocken gezwungenermaßen
Es gibt und kann so etwas nicht
geben
also
Ihr könnt das ja selber mal mit magneten
Ausprobieren der zieht an aber wenn ich ihn wieder trennen will muss sich energie
Aufwenden arbeit es geht nicht anders die physikalischen gesetze sind hier absolut eindeutig hin auch. Wenn es total seltsam effekt den der
Kanten für sie gibt sie haben die physikalischen gesetzen I außer kraft
Gesetzt sie sind einfach und sie gelten leider auf ein magnet motor wenn. Ihr keine videos zu den entwicklungen in diesem bereich
Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann begeht
Ihr die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir. Noch vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Und ihr könnt dann eben themen vorschlagen einfach hier draufklicken
Und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
Klicks zum social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
Genau, glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
elektroautos
revolutionäres neues batterie konzept bis dann
bleibt dran